library
the library is where you find courses
for study
courses are organized into levels based
on difficulty click on a course to view
the lessons inside the course use the
filters on the left to filter the
results
when you find a course that looks
interesting click on the first lesson in
the course to begin studying it
if you finish a course or don't like the
course you have chosen you can return it
to the library at any time and select a
new course
my lessons
lessons that you have selected can be
seen in my lessons where you can take
advantage of the same controls and
filters as in the library if you archive
old lessons they will appear in my
archives
archiving is useful for clearing the my
lesson section of courses that you have
already finished studying
my imports you can also import lessons
and courses to study on the site from
the web and elsewhere these will appear
in my imports simply click the import
lesson button in the library to import a
new lesson
imported lessons can be shared in the
library if they are free of copyright or
if permission has been obtained from the
owner
note that shared lessons must consist of
a text an audio file an image and a
difficulty level
you can also import using the import
bookmarklet just drag the import
bookmarklet to your bookmarks toolbar
then highlight the text that you want to
import
click on the import bookmarklet select
the language of the text you are
importing and click
import